great white sharks is there any sea
beast so feared by humans great whites
like these here off the coast of South
Africa in an area called false Bay can
reach 20 feet in length and weigh up to
5,000 pounds that's more than a pickup
truck but slightly less than a luxury
SUV add this to the fact that great
whites can sprint through the water it
speeds up to 43 miles per hour and it's
no wonder we're afraid of sharks but
should we be honey let's face it they
have great vision they're curious like
cats and they love to taste things that
get their attention but many scientists
believe they don't like to eat humans
they feel about humans the way most
humans feel about lima beans there's
something to eat out of desperation the
fact is great whites sometimes taste
humans for the same reason they taste
other things like motors or boats
they're ampullae of Lorenzini prompt
them to taste it be of course the
ampullae of Lorenzini are gel-filled
electroreceptors found all around the
Sharks snout and head that's these
smaller pores you see here these
receptors are extremely sensitive to
electrical discharges even as small as
point 0 0 5 micro volts that means
anything that gives off the tiniest
electrical charge has to be checked out
including all living creatures in the
sea forget humans and motorboats
great white sharks flip over literally
let's talk about ceilings we know that
some whale species engage in what's
called breaching leaping out of the
water but did you know great white
sharks can breach as well look at these
false Bay great whites put on a show as
they go after a seal decoy being pulled
by a boat if humans are lima beans to
sharks then seals are a double hot fudge
ice cream sundae with three cherries on
top luckily we're yeah lima beans